sono qui per raccontarvi una storia ho
sperato
noiosa una storia iniziata proprio sui
banchi
da cattolico
che anno fa perché ahimè sto iniziando
di picchiare anch'io quando insieme al
mio relatore relatore della tesi di
laurea in giurisprudenza che
sfortunatamente per lui dopo è diventato
anche il mio maestro al mio successivo
percorso universitario nel decidere su
che tema scrivere appunto la tesi di
laurea
abbiamo deciso di provare ad
approfondire il tema della trading
algoritmico ad alta frequenza o high
frequency trading nome in inglese spesso
abbreviato con l'acronimo hft già nome
un po spaventa solo io ero scappata da
qualche tempo dal monte all'economia
della statistica della matematica
finanziaria della finanza con una laurea
in giurisprudenza perché all'alba dei 25
26 anni avevo capito le dà grande volevo
fare l'avvocato penalista ha per
trovarmi anzitutto a studiare che cosa
fosse un algoritmo bene ma non benissimo
direbbero direbbero i giovani d'oggi
in realtà il trading ad alta frequenza
iniziava a e riempiva le prime pagine
dei quotidiani specializzati e non in
quel periodo soprattutto a seguito del
cosiddetto flash crash che era avvenuto
a sul mercato azionario statunitense nel
maggio del 2010 un evento molto molto
strano per utilizzare un eufemismo
nel corso del quale tra le altre cose
l'intero indice dow jones brucia
nell'arco di una quindicina di minuti
circa un trilione di dollari per
recuperare nell'arco dei successivi
quindici minuti quasi tutto quello che
aveva bruciato un evento talmente alieno
alle dinamiche alle normali dinamiche
del mercato che addirittura a trova
spazio ora
shop online del wall street journal tra
le prime pagine storiche del quotidiano
il flash crash è stato un evento sul
quale ovviamente sin da subito i due
watch dog del mercato statunitense la 7
e la sirti si hanno acceso i fari per
capire che ruolo avessero giocato anche
gli algoritmi in quella che può essere
considerata una delle più grandi
distorsioni del mercato finanziario
nella storia moderna evento sul quale
anno che ha portato anche la dottrina in
primis economica e poi quella a
giuridica a cercare di approfondire il
tema del trading ad alta frequenza sia
in da un lato nel cercare di capire come
mai la cava il mondo dell'acca ft è nato
e soprattutto si è sviluppato in maniera
così importante si calcola che circa la
metà delle negoziazioni sul mercato
azionario statunitense oggi sia fatta da
hft quindi con un minimo intervento
dell'uomo
i numeri europa non sono poi così
distanti sia dall'altro lato nel cercare
di capire quali potrebbero essere i
riflessi patologici di alcune delle
tecniche di negoziazione di questi di
questi player del mercato soprattutto in
relazione al reato nella manipolazione
del mercato
in brevissimo il trading ad alta
frequenza si è è nato e si è sviluppato
negli anni 2000 e poi esploso dal 2010 e
soprattutto grazie a un mix tra
innovazione tecnologica da un lato e
substrato legislativo regolamentata
dall'altro mix che ha portato di fatto
alla scomparsa del fattore umano sui
treni floro a quella che vedete
un'immagine della trading floor dello
stock exchange nel 1987 e nel 2017 per
la verità in relazione alla giacca
effetti non è neanche la componente
algoritmica che ha preoccupato così
tanto il commentatore perché il trading
algoritmico esiste quantomeno dagli anni
80 ma soprattutto la componente ad alta
frequenza ha preoccupato come mai perché
diversi studi che hanno provato a
mettere in luce quale sia il limite
massimo del ragionamento strategico del
nostro cervello per esempio mettendo a
confronto i tempi di reazione di esperti
nel gioco degli scacchi contro non
esperti facendo di vedere per le tavole
di gioco e chiedendogli per esempio
serve il re forse fosse sotto scacco
ebbene questi studi hanno fissato in 600
in circa 660 650 millisecondi il limite
massimo del ragionamento strategico
della del cervello umano che è
un'eternità per il ragionamento
algoritmico e in particolare per gli
operatori algoritmici ecco che in
relazione alla cai feti e soprattutto al
fatto che si muovono in dimensioni
temporali inaccessibili al nostro
cervello
molto si è detto e molto si è scritto e
le contrapposizioni ossimori che si sono
davvero sprecate angeli e demoni dottor
jekyll e mister hyde il più ne ha più ne
metta
da un lato chi sostiene che facciano
bene alla loro presenza faccia bene al
mercato perché migliorano la press
discovery e assicurano le qui dal
mercato dall'altro lato chi sottolinea
che facciano male al mercato perché la
liquidità che forniscono è solo
apparente e soprattutto perché alcune
teche loro tecniche di negoziazione
potrebbe configurare manipolazione
però a ben vedere quando il discorso e
quando alcuni esponenti della dottrina
hanno provato ad indagare e relazionale
apri manipolazione del mercato
il terreno è diventato molto scivoloso
soprattutto in relazione alla
tradizionale grammatica del penalista
perché davanti a un reato che viene
tradizionalmente descritto come
strutturalmente doloso dove il ruolo
dell'intento come lo chiamano negli
stati uniti quindi dell'elemento
psicologico in particolare della
declinazione del dolo è molto importante
quindi l'abolizione la rappresentazione
di un fatto di reato
ebbene proiettare la tradizionale
grammatica del penalista a delle scelte
di negoziazione prese in quasi totale
autonomia da una macchina all'interno di
dimensioni temporali veramente
inaccessibili al nostro cervello non è
poi così semplice
e in effetti i casi di contestazioni di
manipolazione del mercato in relazione
al fenomeno della hrt nonostante vi
siano diversi studi empirici che
evidenziano come alcune delle tecniche
di trading potrebbero astrattamente
configurare manipolazione del mercato si
contano davvero sulle sulle dita di una
mano
purtroppo per me i miei studi è il mio
approfondimento di questo tema era solo
un assaggio delle problematiche che
dovrà affrontare il penalista in futuro
perché a seguito della mia laurea ho
fatto la malsana scelta di andare a
studiare negli stati uniti dove partendo
dal tema del trinka ad alta frequenza
poi ho potuto ampliare il i miei studi
al tema più ampio dell'intelligenza
artificiale
se in relazione macca effettive queste
contrapposizioni ossimori che si sono
davvero sprecate
in relazione all intelligenza
artificiale che hanno raggiunto la
massima scala portando da un lato
importantissimi esponenti delle più
importanti società tecnologiche al mondo
è importantissimi professori a
sottolineare come l'intelligenza
artificiale sia la cosa alla quale la
cosa più importante alla quale l'umanità
stia lavorando non guardando al futuro
ma al presente nei minuti che mi restano
in questa presentazione vorrei provare a
focalizzare la vostra attenzione sul
settore di cui mi occupo sul diritto
penale e provare a capire quali siano
gli ambiti di applicazione che già oggi
esistono dell'intelligenza artificiale
nel diritto penale il quale siano però
le problematiche che questa applicazione
se non controllata
e se non occulata potrebbe potrebbe
causare perché provando a immaginare
come ho provato a fare nelle slide a un
fatto di reato e al sistema che di
solito un ordinamento giuridico
costruisce attorno a un fatto di reato
che si compone di un momento preventivo
e di un momento repressivo a ben vedere
già oggi intelligenza artificiale viene
utilizzata magari non in italia ma
sicuramente altrove in tutti questi
sotto sotto settori ma anche a vedere al
fatto di reato insieme possiamo
sicuramente distinguere era un
potenziale utilizzo criminale dei
sistemi di intelligenza artificiale alla
domanda delle domande che è la
possibilità o meno che una macchina
possa commettere astrattamente un fatto
di reato
ora andando velocemente sulla
prevenzione dell'utilizzo
dell'intelligenza artificiale nella
prevenzione del crimine sono ormai
diversi gli studi che evidenziano quali
possano essere i modi di applicazione
dell'intelligenza artificiale ad esempio
un report di interpol e unicri che
distingue quattro categorie di di
utilizzo dei sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale quelle solo in una fase di
concetto quelli in una fase di prototipo
quelle in fase di testing e quelle già
utilizzate
gli esempi sono molteplici utilizzo di
droni
il confine o controllare le carceri
utilizzo di sistemi audio video per
controllare i detenuti più pericolosi
fino ad arrivare ai sistemi di pulizia
predittiva che pongono l'ambizione di
prevedere nel tempo e nello spazio
la commissione di crimini quasi in una
realtà distopica alla minority report
ora a me sembra che accanto ai
tradizionali
concetti che accompagnano ogni manuale
del diritto penale di prevenzione
generale ossia l'assunto secondo cui la
minaccia di pena serva distogliere la
generalità dei consociati a commettere
crimini o la prevenzione cosiddetta
speciale ossia l'idea che infliggere una
pena nei confronti di una persona serve
a prevenire la commissione da parte di
queste persone di altri reati nel futuro
si stia giungendo una prevenzione per
così dire artificiale che non so quanto
sia coperta al momento dalle necessarie
garanzie che il diritto penale in teoria
richiede anche solo nella fase in cui io
accusi una persona di un determinato
fatto il reato perché se andiamo a
vedere ai media pro ii già ci sono stati
è il caso ad esempio di robert williams
che vedete sulla slide accusato
falsamente e ingiustamente di un reato
che mai aveva commesso ma i casi già
iniziano a moltiplicarsi di errori nel
riconoscimento facciale ad esempio per
poter gli algoritmi che portano agli
arresti portano alle tensioni per
esempio di 10 giorni poi vengono
rilasciati ma a mio modo di vedere anche
solo l'accusa ingiusta nei confronti
una persona è qualcosa che dovrebbe che
dovrebbe far riflettere e attenzione
questo non è un discorso è limitato solo
agli stati uniti perché è ad esempio
l'ottimo lavoro che svolge algoritmi
watch un istituto che monitora
sull'applicazione di questi sistemi
anche in europa che ad esempio evidenzia
un report pubblicato qualche mese fa
come in italia siano almeno due i
sistemi di polizia predittiva che sono
al momento in fase di testing a milano a
napoli a salerno e in altre città
d'italia o com'era poco prima che gli
stadi venissero chiusi per colpa della
pandemia un'idea delle più alte cariche
della lega serie a di installare delle
telecamere dei sistemi di sound rumor
per cercare di intercettare insulti
razzisti negli stadi
passando poi all'utilizzo dei sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale nella
repressione del crimine quindi nella
macchina della giustizia quando si mette
in moto un processo penale o ancora
nella macchina che riguarda l'esecuzione
della pena
questo tema non riguarda per la verità
l'italia che io sappia non ci sono dei
sistemi utilizzati a oggi negli stati
uniti sono più di una sessantina a e in
particolare uno ad esempio è diventato
molto importante ha utilizzato nel
wisconsin e in altri stati si chiama
compass per aiutare i giudici nel
giudizio di recidiva nhtsa via imputati
deliziosa quale può dipendere la libertà
condizionale dal quale può dipendere una
condanna più grave dal quale può
dipendere ha appunto la reclusione o
meno di un soggetto che bene però
repubblica la chiamava organizzazione no
profit che ha provato a indy a indagare
su questo sistema ha messo in luce come
questo algoritmo sistematicamente
discriminasse persone di colore e
discriminasse minoranze razziali
poi arriva il tema dei temi come il che
mando tutti i temi vengono affrontati
all'ultimo
è in poche battute no sto scherzando che
il tema della responsabilità dalla
possibilità o meno di utilizzare i
sistemi di intelligenza artificiale per
commettere dei reati o della commissione
di fatti dei reati da parte di sistemi
di intelligenza artificiale per quanto
riguarda il primo aspetto le
problematiche non ruotano tanto attorno
alla responsabilità individuale della
persona fisica e chiaro che la
responsabilità rimane in capo alla
persona fisica
diversi studi come ad esempio quello
dell'università di oxford e altri
importantissimi enti di ricerca che vi
ho messo sulle slide evidenziano come in
relazione a questi fenomeni
sarà molto complesso andare a capire chi
c'è dietro
l'utilizzo malicious come a parla il
report il sistema di intelligenza
artificiale e come molto penetranti
potrebbero essere questi attacchi si
pensi ad cyber attacchi molto molto
sofisticati che potrebbero colpire le
industrie strategiche potrebbero colpire
gli ospedali si pensi ancora a tutto il
mondo molto delicato delle feci news e
dei deep fake sa che come diversi
importantissime voci da harari in giù
sottolineano che potrebbe addirittura
mettere in pericolo la democrazia le
democrazie moderne
da ultimo il tema dei temi può o meno
una macchina commette un reato
sì e no nel senso che astrattamente
potrebbe farlo sono già successi dagli
incidenti mortali degli incidenti fatali
a causa di auto guida autonoma
in entrambi i casi c'era un driver che
guidava e quindi il pubblico ministero
ha deciso di colpevolizzare comunque la
persona che avrebbe dovuto tenere
le mani sul volante ma stiamo andando
verso un condomio messo la macchina di
zucca una società controllata da amazon
che ha lanciato un paio di mesi fa
arriveranno le macchine che non avranno
più nessuno che le guida e in quel caso
nell'ipotesi in cui qualcosa di brutto
dovesse succedere chi deve rispondere di
un fatto penalmente rilevante anche qui
in dottrina ci sta iniziando a domandare
è un tema molto complesso
io al momento non ho non ho la risposta
però credo che in considerazione del
fatto che l'intelligenza artificiale e
qui per rimanere sia arrivato il momento
di discutere di questi temi di discutere
su chi debba rispondere di un incidente
stradale
fatale nell'ipotesi in cui sia una
macchina ad averlo commesso se o meno un
medico debba rispondere su una diagnosi
effettuata da un sistema di intelligenza
artificiale sbagliata se o meno una e
debba rispondere di una manipolazione
del mercato commessa da un algoritmo io
non mi spingo così oltre come chi in
dottrina sostiene che sia arrivato il
momento di colpevolizzare le macchine
questo è un discorso che a me ricorda
molto i processi che facevamo nel
medioevo nei confronti degli animali o
quelli che facevamo fino a qualche
centinaia anni fa contro gli oggetti
contro gli oggetti ha però credo sia
arrivato il momento di parlare sul se
possa essere fatta risalire a una
persona fisica la responsabilità per una
scelta ha preso da una macchina perché
le macchine se sono intelligenti saranno
fallibili io vorrei chiudere con una
frase di alan turing a pronunciata
qualche anno prima in una conferenza
qualche anno prima della pubblicazione
del suo paper in cui presentò il tour in
testa ormai ripe per te citati nella
storia dell'accademia la mente geniale
di turin ci ricordava come se ci
aspettiamo che la macchina sia
infallibile non può essere anche
intelligente e visto che le macchine
intelligenti sono qui per rimanere le
macchine dirigenti falliranno
secondo me era importante discutere di
chi come e perché debba rispondere
nell'ipotesi in cui una macchina
intelligente fallirà commettendo anche
un fatto di reato grazie a tokyo